the youtube come up soon oh i see it
okay so we are all set
all right good morning everybody welcome
to the election law committee welcome to
our members
um hello everybody um as
i'm reading the following notice as
required this allows us to meet
electronically and as chair of the
election law committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the coven 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order 20
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this particular meeting is a committee
orientation meeting there will be no
votes taken
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously
however in according with the emergency
order i'm confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has the ability to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary
participate in the meeting by zoom the
zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting does comply with house
rules and
rsa 91 a and anyone who has problems
accessing this meeting please call 271
3600 or email
hcs at leg
dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event at some point during this
meeting we learned that the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and it will be
rescheduled
at this time i'm going to introduce pam
smarling from the house committee
research office
who is on the meeting assisting us
we have some people in attendance from
the secretary of state's office who
we will be hearing from and
i'd like to start the meeting by taking
a roll call attendance
and when each member states their
affirms that they're present for the
meeting electronically
please state whether there is anyone
else in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know
and if whoever in the meeting with you
has four legs
um we're going to be giving them a quiz
at the end to see
how they listened natalie wells has
representative wells has agreed to serve
as clerk
um representative wells do you want to
venture to
take the role or would you like me to do
it
it's it's fine if you'd like to all
right
do it why you take the plunge
oh my goodness you got the list right
i do all right so we're going to go down
this list the
the list i believe we're going to
operate on um
is by party by um
rank in regards to service terms there
is nothing personal about the order of
this
name and if you have a z this may be
your opportunity to be at the front of
the line so
um representative wells why don't you
take the role
okay first one is representative griffin
here and there is no one with me today
okay representative mcdonald i'm here
and i'm alone
okay uh representative o'brien
root home o'brien
okay keep going i saw him okay kathy
kathy you are you need to unmute
yourself
representative o'brien sorry okay
all right i see her okay muted
yeah you are now
right okay august my cat my dog
okay representative sweeney i am here
and i am by myself
okay representative hayward
uh by phone
i don't know if he's able to
do his star sex or you reviewed it
representative hayward did i just hear
you all right why don't we keep going
and hopefully that'll get worked out
during the course of the meeting
okay i see his name there um yeah and he
just
i'm sorry to interject he has
communicated with me by email and told
me that he can hear fine
and asked how he could be heard and i i
you know gave him the star six um
suggestion and apparently it's not
working but um
that's all i know so why don't you give
him um
the number 271 3600
to see if someone can help him log on
your we need your assistance directly or
i would have you help them
thank you all right representative wells
why don't you continue
uh representative mooney i'm present and
alone okay uh
representation i'm here
in um alone okay
representative barry aaron alone
representative crone i don't know if i'm
saying it right
now he was here a minute ago
representative groan all right
moving on i'm here here i'm here and i'm
alone
okay uh let's see representative quailey
here and myself okay
myself i'm here representative cody
here and alone representative ward
here with two family members in the
house
okay um representative bergeron
i'm present and there's no one in the
room with me
okay representative sandler
uh present and there's no one in the
room with me at present
okay uh representative hammer
i'm present and i have my dog
representative lane i'm present and i am
alone in the room
uh representative freitas
i am alone in the room present and alone
okay representative hamlet
hey i am here and my son is in another
room and i'm in my home
okay and representative murrehead
president alone okay that's it
thank you representative wells
i want to welcome everybody to this
meeting
um what i'd like to do first is to do a
little introduction of
everybody to each other on the committee
um i've had the privilege to serve with
a number of you
in prior terms and many of you on this
committee
and i look forward to the upcoming
session
i am a representative of goffstown new
hampshire
this is my fourth term and
this is my second session
as chair of this committee in my first
term i was clerk of this committee and
just to
just so you know that things don't
always go like you planned i have never
asked in my committee assignments to be
on election law
so here we are nonetheless um
and i'm looking forward to the upcoming
year
i want to thank representative wells for
agreeing to be clerk
and i want to welcome representative
mcdonald to the committee
as my vice chair we all have a pretty
challenging year
ahead of us with this meeting format
i know not everybody is happy with it
and i know for some people they consider
it to be a medical necessity
and we need to somehow accommodate all
those views and needs as we go forward
with committee meetings
as you can see we are having this
committee meeting remotely
so committee meetings will proceed with
members being able to attend remotely
and we will talk about that a little bit
more at the end
of the meeting i will point out
that we have been given the dubious
distinction
of having the first public hearing
and after being asked to schedule one
bill
i got the call and said well why don't
you do two more
and we'll talk about how we've ended up
being the first committee with
the first three bills um because we're
going to be doing that
a week from now so i hope you're
all as excited to be on this committee
as i am
and i'm looking forward to working with
all of you as we try to get the bugs out
of the system
and have a meaningful session of
participating as best we all can
given the circumstances so having said
that
i'm going to turn to my vice chair and
ask him to
introduce himself to the committee and
then i'm going to jump around the
committee list here
um and ask you to introduce yourself
representative mcdonald
thank you madam chairman and um i'm
looking forward to working with you and
everyone else on the committee
i was a little more fortunate than you
or this was my first choice
and i'm grateful to have the opportunity
to serve on this committee
clearly we have a lot of work to do it's
an important
uh function for the for the state for
the
legislature and i think we have some
very important
issues to deal with i'm currently in my
first term here in the new hampshire
house of representatives although i've
been involved
in the political process for quite a few
years
i represent rockingham county district
five which is the town of londonderry
previous to becoming a member of the new
hampshire house i
served for 23 years in the new hampshire
department of health and human services
i retired in june of 2019 as the senior
fraud investigator
senior welfare fraud investigator for
the department
prior to that i was in the window
manufacturing business for 19 years
among other things i've done i've been
chairman of the new hampshire republican
party
and also been republican national
committee man for new hampshire
and again i look forward to working with
you all and
and then dealing with the important
issues that lie ahead
thank you representative mcdonald
representative ward
is with us this morning representative
ward
i've had the privilege of working with
on this committee before and
representative ward brings a lot of
knowledge to this process both by virtue
of himself
and someone who he resides with so good
morning representative ward how are you
uh representative thank you for the nice
remarks i do listen to my wife from time
to time
she knows more about this than i do but
i represent ward 4 in portsmouth
this is my fifth term all which have
been on election law which i enjoy very
much so
glad to get the ball rolling once again
thank you thank you
um representative mooney welcome to
election law
thank you madam chairman and by mr vice
chairman
my name is maureen mooney and i
represent and live
in the town of merrimack here in
hillsborough county
this is actually my fourth term i
served in the house from 2003
to 2008. during that time i was on the
judiciary committee
and in my last term i was also on the
rules committee
and an assistant republican leader
i want to particularly point out
representative david cody
because he was the chairman of the
judiciary committee when i served in my
third term
back in 2007-2008 and so
it's great to be and serve on a
committee with him as well
and so i look forward also to serving
and getting to know all of you
thank you thank you representative moody
uh representative bergeron also
joins the election law committee again
and has
a lot of experience that it has been
helpful in the past good morning
representative bergeron
good morning representative griffin and
thank you this is uh
my third term in the legislature last
session i was on election law
my first term i served on municipal and
county government
although that was 49 years ago
prior to my retirement in 2015 i had
spent 16 years as city clerk in nashua
and for the five years prior to that i
was deputy clerk in manchester
responsible for elections and licensing
so i've found
election law to be a very comfortable
fit for me and
i've enjoyed it very much i look forward
to the coming session as well
thank you thank you um
representative barry joins us in his
first term here i believe at the state
house good morning representative barry
good morning good morning everyone i'm
ross berry i represent um
hillsborough 44 which is south
manchester in
the town of litchfield i do a lot of
different things but
i'm a landlord small business owner that
sort of deal
i've worked in elections before and i'm
super excited for all the awesome things
that we're going to do this year
thank you representative barry
representative sandler
welcome back to election law
good morning unmute here i am hi
um yeah i'm kat sandler i represent
stratford county district 21 which is a
plateau district it includes dover
somersworth and rollinsford
as well as two wards in dover
the fifth and sixth
i am a us army veteran and a retired
attorney
uh moved to new hampshire
gosh going on six years now and uh
very happy to be a member of the
legislature and of this particular
committee it's
uh it's a great place to work thank you
representative prudhomme o'brien um
is also returning to the election law
committee i had the chance to sit next
to her a few
few meetings last year good morning how
are you good morning
uh i hope everyone can hear me
and i'm happy to be on this committee
again uh
this was my first choice i was on this
committee one time before prior to that
i was on the labor committee and
before that in real life i i was a
musical instrument maker for many years
i made piccolos and flutes
i then stayed home with my children
and taught them at home until they went
to high school
and i've continued to care for my family
i had
my mother-in-law with us until she
recently passed
this last week and the age of 98
so that was a real gift um
i really am passionate about this issue
it started in 2016 for me when i ran
again for the house of representatives
here in derry and we had some
problems with our election and
better and have been improved upon and
things are much better in my community
but it it was a real wake-up call for me
and really made me see the importance of
election integrity
and how important that is for the
community to see
that elections are run well because they
were the issues
that was the issue that i would say
people in my community talk to me about
the most
and we're most concerned about so it's
very important and
thank you all for serving well thank you
uh representative hammer returns and has
been an
early morning victim of the use of my
new phone
in response i i hope that somehow
everything was spelt correctly
um and i do want to let the committee
know that i am
expecting a call that i might have to
take at which point
i will step out and ask my vice chair
wayne mcdonald along with
uh pam smarling's assistance to take
over
it should be a brief call representative
hammer how are you this morning
hi good morning good morning um
i'm back on second term in election law
i represent ward 10 in manchester i'm
also ward clerk for manchester
um just happy to be back
thank you representative sweeney
good morning i know i saw you somewhere
yes good morning madam chair
uh i'm excited to be back on election
law i had previously served in the house
representing rockingham eight
the town of salem from 2012 to 2016.
uh served those two terms on election
law um and this is my
first returning term to the house since
then
uh and i'm excited to be on election law
and work with all of you
um on the matters that affect our
committee and that will be presented for
and i'm just really excited for the term
so thank you thank you good morning
representative hamlet
uh welcome to election law
thank you madam chair um
yes uh so i live in portsmouth this is
my first term
in the house and i'm very excited to be
on the election law committee
i've been the moderator for portsmouth
ward 3 for the past couple
of terms my district is a floaterial
i have portsmouth ward 3 greenland
newington and northampton which has been
fascinating getting to know lots of
people
in those towns and um
let's see i've been retired for two
years and i worked for 29 years
for the state uh the last 19
of which were for the child support
office i
i was a child support officer so i'm
very happy to be here
thank you thank you uh
representative growing good morning
good morning thank you madam chair um
i'm
from rochester represent stratford
ward or district 23 wards two and three
in
in rochester um that first term in the
house
i did serve one term in the senate uh i
have the privilege of going from
being simply senator to being honorable
and i appreciate that
um i served on
the edna committee and judiciary
committee in the senate as well as
on jalcar and election law is my first
choice here i'm looking forward to
serving with all of you
well thanks for joining us uh
representative lane
is on election law again this year um
good morning representative lane how are
you good morning madam chairman
i'm fine this is my second term
and i was on election law last term and
um it was my first choice too both times
and i'm looking forward to working on it
again so thank you
um in the interest of full disclosure um
i think we have a lot of attorneys on
this committee
whether actively practicing or retired
all the attorneys practicing are retired
please raise their hand and i see the
whole picture can i do a whole picture
so we've got one two three
three hands up there so uh we are in
dangerous territory i just heard
somebody ask about the whole picture
um pam are you with us
yes yes um i'm
i'm gonna take a break right now you
want to go through
the options for screen in case
we don't have everybody on the tile
format or do we have
options yes you've got two options
between
speaker view and gallery view
and we definitely um recommend gallery
view so you can see
all the different files and how would
you do that
on the upper right hand um
side of my screen there's the toggle
or ability to go between speaker view
and gallery view sometimes it says
speaker view or sometimes you see a
grid with all the little you know like
like
nine squares like a telephone pad grid
like a telephone pad so if you toggle
between the two
um you should be able to
choose your gallery view and if you were
on gallery view the person speaking will
be
highlighted in some format so
your screen right now because i am
talking my screen is showing a sort of
yellowish green
frame around it so if someone is talking
and you're not sure who it is
if you just do a soft eye look at the
screen and look for that highlight
you'll be able to
um narrow in on who it is that's
speaking
and of course we've all learned that
on the bottom left you have the ability
to stop the video
and keep your microphone on
and you can also obviously click
yourself
back on we appreciate that there might
be things during committee meetings that
you need to take care of um
when we are physically in session there
are times that people have to get up and
leave the room during
discussion or public comment um
and we need to sort of decide i i think
maybe um if you've got your camera on at
that point maybe you
we need to sort of figure out what works
better
as to whether or not leaving a blank
screen on makes more sense so we know
you're not there
or whether or not it makes more sense to
just turn the video camera off
um that may be a little bit of personal
preference but
i think we'll sort of figure those
things out as we go along does anybody
else have any questions
about the actual operation of the zoom
screen
yeah the only other feature that that is
especially
important is the raised hand feature and
i i
presume everybody knows how to to raise
their hand
but in case you just need a refresher
it's down at the bottom of the
participants list
um as an option
and i know it's different on different
different
systems like if your ipad or phone it
may differ
but um that's important and as as while
i'm talking while i have the
highlighted screen i just want to say
that i i've been turning my video off
um during you know one once that meeting
gets going
i'm not gone i'm right here but i am you
know answering email and doing some
other things which i find distracting to
you know for you to see me moving around
answering the phone
that's the only reason i'm turning my
video off
so certainly if you ask me something
i'll i'll respond
great thank you for that all right if if
members have questions about how to do
the zoom or what's going on or what
they're seeing um i'm going to ask you
to interrupt right away
especially on these first few meetings
things are going to pop up you're going
to have questions
and it's better to get them resolved
right away and if you're having the
problem it probably means somebody else
has
either at that moment or in the future
all right we have a few more members
i just um the other thing is
representative hayward we've been
um emailing back and forth with him
but i don't know if he got the latest
email because he's on his phone it's
it's it's um
it's been a challenge for him to listen
i think and and also look at his email
so representative
hayward if you could try signing off
just just hanging up and dialing back in
again
we're thinking maybe you could just have
a bad connection and you'll be able to
unmute and mute yourself
if you get a better connection so
or you know he's i'm able to communicate
with him by email he says he can hear
everything but he just can't unmute
himself
all right so if you can keep
communicating with him that would be
great
okay all right back to members
representative terozian
um good morning we haven't had the
opportunity to hear from you how
are you
good thank you madam chair and members
of the committee
again i'm peter teroshan i represent
rockingham county 14 which is the town
of atkinson and plaistow
i just got elected to my third term i'm
proud to say i've
brought my uh list in the
district for the third time and only
time i've run with the most votes
i was on the transportation committee
my last two terms decided i wanted to
make a change to election law and i'll
i'll tell you why in a minute
but just a quick uh rundown on me um
i'm a coast guard veteran i'm not an
attorney so i guess i'm in the minority
on this committee a little bit of some
of the things i've done in the past
um i'm a retired airline pilot i work
for
four different airlines i was
on the board of directors of the airline
pilot association which is the largest
pilot union in the world my last airline
i was
president of the pilot union
i so those were a couple of elected
positions i had
outside of politics if you will
i was also in the aircraft charter
business where i was president ceo of an
aircraft charter
in scheduled freight company that i
actually founded
in my town i was on the conflict of
interest board
for one term i'm currently
finishing out my sixth year my second
three-year term on the
municipal budget committee i may run for
another
three years i do i need to sign up for
course on thursday
in my time so far up here here is a rep
i've filled in on many committees um
probably 75 percent of the committees i
filled in
one point or another this time i decided
to
give election law a try uh
i believe we have important work to do
um i certainly value
and we need to ensure that we have free
fair honest
and secure elections and i think we got
our work cut out for us um
this term and
um that's kind of why i want to get up
on this
um committee
so with that i'll uh i'll turn it back
to the chair
thank you thank you um
joining us on election law is
representative freitas
yes good morning how are you i'm very
well thank you and i'm looking forward
to working on this committee i was
happy to be chosen this is my fourth
term and i've been with health and human
services
and elderly affairs because i thought of
elderly affair
nice thing now that i've retired from
teaching and i love to teaching it's a
good
opportunity to listen and participate
and that's why these
meetings these committee meetings in
person i'm so looking forward to getting
to that i'm a select man been a
selectman for 20 years so i'm right on
the front lines with
election activities and election
problems so i'm really looking forward
to working with the committee
thank you for writing
representative good morning
morning thank you madam chairman uh i'm
jim corley i'm
live in rindge i've lived here 20 years
ago
i've lived here 20 years i was a
selectman from 2016 to 2019 and
served as the chairman of that board for
the last half of my term
i represent chester 11 which consists of
rinj and fitzwilliam
my professional background academically
i studied physics for
many many years and when i escaped
graduate school i went on to become a
r d engineer in uh defense in
uh commercial industries for a number of
years until i retired some years ago
the election law committee was among my
choices i can't say first or second i
didn't really rank them in my own mind
and i'm really happy to be on this
committee i think it's important work
and i'm looking forward to contributing
to it
and it's a pleasure to meet you all and
i'm looking forward to when we get a
chance to meet in person
thank you very much thank you
representative wells we
put you right into the fire with roll
call a little earlier this morning
good morning good morning okay
this um thank you madam chair vice chair
um i have the flotarial of merrimack 25
which is andover danbury salisbury
warner and webster this is my second
term here for uh election law
the great representative barbara griffin
and um
which was in 2016 and 18
and i'm a retired business person um
and i've been up here now for 20 years
and just love it
and uh election law is very important to
our state
and uh this is why i signed up again for
it
thank you thank you
representative muirhead
thank you i represent lyme and
hanover this is my first term i'm
not a lawyer i'm a teacher and very much
looking forward to learning about the
committee's work
thank you for having me thank you for
joining us we look
we all look forward to working with you
and each other um
the last committee member here that i
believe we can hear from because
representative haywood as far as i oh
nope
representative hayward is still i don't
believe with us
um is representative cody um
i have in my mind uh saved the best for
last
i have had the privilege of serving with
representative cody now
every term in some capacity on this
committee
and i still remember the first time he
introduced himself
as to the service he has done for the
state
in this role um so i consider it a
privilege to
be back with him good morning
representative cody
good morning madam chair and thank you
very much for the kind words it's a
pleasure to be here with you
i am david cody i am from nashua i
represent nashua ward 4
and this is my 20th term in the
legislature and i'm delighted to serve
with all of you
in reference to representative mooney
i'm delighted she finally took my advice
and decided to come back again after a
period of time
and i look forward to serving with her
again and representative sweeney who's a
former member of this committee
thank you very much look forward to
serving with all of you of course
thank you everybody um
madam chairman i just have a recent word
from representative hayward he's going
to remain as he is he
he's he tried hanging up and coming back
in one time and
and still has the same problem so he's
he's okay with just listening
um and you know hopefully we can come up
with a better solution for
the hearings on on friday clearly but
but he's going to stay this way
all right so good morning representative
hayward we're glad you can join us we're
going to be hearing uh a presentation
um so the committee knows i do expect
there to be some
screenshots so we're going to get some
practice and how to do that because i
need to tell you it
it annoys me terribly to have these
screenshots of the committee
and of the paperwork and not be able to
see the committee so we're going to see
how that
works um and in that regards
uh do we have i see that
um deputy secretary scanlon is with us
generally in the past what we have done
for orientation for election law is here
from the secretary of state's office
election is a a little bit different
from other committees first of all law
is in our title election law and
we the state has a
division of operations that is
essentially devoted to the
administration of elections
the state through the secretary of
state's office administers its elections
and it administers its elections
entirely by law
not by rule you heard a reference
of i think representative growing
discussed what
he was in the senate he was on jail car
there are
most agencies operate by rules
the elections in this state are governed
by statute and
so when we go to take a look at the
bills for next week you're going to see
some bills that go on for pages and
pages
and pages and that's because they are
actually dealing with the law
as it is currently codified and the
changes are made to that law
in specific form by word
so that what this committee decides to
bring forward to the body and what the
body passes
goes directly into law and is not
subject to
rule making by the administrative agency
so in that regards we asked the
secretary of state's office to join us
to
sort of bring us up to date every two
years when we reassemble it is
after a general election i am hoping
that we're going to be able to hear
a little bit about what the numbers were
for our election
this past fall in regards to
participation
and i'm also hoping that we're going to
hear a little bit about what laws govern
our operation here in the state because
of course there are federal laws
that govern our general elections as
compared to
our municipal elections which we'll be
dealing with directly next week
pam is i see
that
dave scanlon and um secretary of state
gardner both appear to be in
separate links all right so i'm going to
try and promote
to a panelist both gentlemen
from the secretary of state secretary
gardner and
deputy secretary
scanlan but i i can't the bottom of the
list
w garden oh
okay the other um handy
thing to do in this situation actually
is if
somebody in the attendees raises their
hand they pop to the top of the list
and so you can see that they're
alphabetical by their first
names which is you know sometimes you
know their first names but
it's easiest ask them to raise their
hand pop to the top of the list then you
can find them
all right and they will join my
panelists list
by in alphabetical order apparently is
that how this works
alphabetical oh i don't know how they
joined the book on my screen deputy
scanlon is showing up
towards the top and secretary gardner is
now at the bottom
okay i mean which is fine i just want to
be able to find them
and because we just added them
they have gone to the end
of my tiles a board member committee
members will note
uh we now have more panelists than
tiles so if you go to the middle of your
screen
on excuse me the side of your
your panel on the right or left you will
see a one of
two if you're on the first page and if
you
uh click it you will go to two of two
the tiles will automatically fill
so there will be overlap but we can see
i can see deputy scanlon
and secretary gardner
online welcome
to the meeting deputy
scanlon i'm speaking directly to you
because on my screen it appears that
secretary gardner
is muted so i'm not sure what's
happening there good morning
good morning ma'am sharon thank you and
secretary gardner is with us
uh we're in the same office but in
different rooms
and to need my assistance in getting his
picture up uh in his tile and also
unmuted so i'll be happy to do that
in just a second uh before we get
started you know i want to say it's
great to see a lot of very familiar
faces
on the committee and i look forward to
working with
those members that we've worked with in
the past and also
the new ones that are uh also on the
committee um we look forward to
meeting you hopefully in person in the
not too distant future but
um you know in the meantime uh through
this format
um before we get into our presentation
just a
couple of housekeeping things we like to
be a resource for the committee
and the members of the committee to the
extent that we're able to
we do have some publications that the
veteran members of the committee
have and we'll certainly get these to
the newer members
um it would be helpful if you could send
us an email
with your mailing address and we're
happy to send these materials to you
otherwise you can wait until we see you
in person
or you can visit the office and we can
hand them all over but
we have the election law book which has
all of the pertinent
laws related to elections and most of
the
statutes that you'll be dealing with
with the legislation that you'll be
taking up this session
we also have state constitutions that
are available this is also a very
important
document for the work that you do
we have an election procedure manual
that because of the work you do keeps
getting
thicker and thicker every year and and
the last
uh last session because of the covet
situation was no
exception to that but this is the the
bible for local election officials
and it is a product of the work that you
do
and after uh you know after the
second session of the biennium prior to
the elections
we put all the updates related to the
election laws
in this booklet and then these are
mailed to every election official
in the state of new hampshire and then
the last
helpful publication you'll find is the
political calendar
this is simply a two-year calendar but
it has all the important deadlines
and and the related statutes that
accompany those deadlines
related to anything with elections so
these will be dates for filing for
office
you know when the actual primaries are
held when the supervisors of the
checklist have to meet
the only information that is a little
lacking in here are dates related to
senate bill 2 elections and the reason
for that is
there's flexibility in those dates at
the local level and so it's really
difficult for us
to just uh you know put that as a
calendar date in this publication
but otherwise this is a really helpful
document
to have that you should be aware of um
so with that i'm just going to
jump over to the other office and help
bill get onto his screen
and uh so just give me deputy scanlan
before you go
um you mentioned emailing the office
is there an email address if people want
need to be sent the material you just
saw because they don't
have it yeah probably the best thing is
just email me directly
and my email address excuse me it's
david
dot scanlan and that's s-c-a-n-l-a-n
at sos
thank you you also mentioned that
members could come by to pick up the
material directly
if they so desired if they wanted to
come and do that
who should they call uh they can just
call the secretary of state's office
and that the main number here is
271-3242
and uh let them know that you're a
representative on the election law
committee
uh the building at the moment is not
open and and so
entry is restricted but if they won't
let you in the building to come up to
the office room
204 of the state house uh we're happy to
bring the materials down and meet you at
the side entrance
if you manage to get into the building
room 204 is
at the essentially at the end of the
ramp which enters
into the ante room of representatives
hall um
finally just based on what you said you
referenced
sb2 elections in the political calendar
if you're from an sb2 town community um
you know what that means but
does that sp2 have any relation to the
sb2
that we have on our calendar for hearing
next week uh
it does not the the sb2 that i'm
referring to was a senate bill that
passed back in the mid 90s
uh that recreated that created you know
the official ballot form of town meeting
um and and that that moniker stuck
and uh here we are a couple decades
later and you know that
activity that form of town meeting is uh
still referred to as senate bill 2. so
we have a senate bill 2
that could affect senate bill 2. you
have well you have senate bill
too yeah
i have to look at it more closely but
the senate bill two that is currently
before you
i believe is designed to help towns
uh get through the town meeting coming
to town meeting as compared to the sb2
yeah with with concerns related to coven
so
i'm sure that senate bill 2 is a portion
of that
all right well we'll be hearing more
about that later thank you does anybody
have any questions for deputy scanlan
before
uh we switch tables here in the
secretary's office just uh just follow
me
peter representative derozan thank you
madam chair
yes um i think we all understand that
the building is closed but
if we called your office could we make
an appointment to come up when we come
up and pick up that material
absolutely very good thank you
happy to escort you up thank you
okay so i'm not going anywhere but i see
representative
hammer has her hand raised yes i had a
question
i had emailed the secretary of state's
email i have a constituent who want to
know
what election
voting machine were used
because he was afraid that if we were
using a certain type
it wasn't keeping track of all the
correct votes
that is a frequently asked question
after the last election and
concerns that were raised with uh
voting equipment that is uh manufactured
by
a company called dominion and
the the optical scan counting device
that is used in new hampshire
has been used for probably at least 25
years now they're they're
they're rapidly approaching the end of
their
functional life but they are still in
use
as they are in use in vermont and
connecticut and
you know other places in new england
those
dominion the company that has the
concerns raised about it
owns the intellectual property of the
accuvope machine
that is used in new hampshire even
though it had nothing to do with the
manufacturing of the machine
the firmware that is in the machine
which is a form of software
was not created by dominion and the
the memory cards that are used are not
uh
programmed by dominion but they're
programmed by a local vendor
known as lhs associates um
so uh
the the short answer to your question is
uh no those are not the machines that uh
that the where the issues were raised
related to dominion
uh equipment and software um they've
actually been a really good workhorse
uh over the decades um occasionally you
know we have some accounts that
that don't make sense but but 99.9
of the time as long as the voter
accurately marks the ballot
according to the instructions those
devices will count those ballots
properly
thank you i did send him an email
and assured him that new hampshire's
secretary of state's office is accurate
and
we are right on board so thank you
you're welcome so uh give me give me 30
seconds and i'll get secretary gardner
on the on the on the show here
[Music]
yeah that's the archives okay but you're
all
okay hello
everyone it's a pleasure
to be with you the veteran members and
the new members uh this is a
your committee's a very special
committee in the legislature
and it has been over all the years
as chair griffin
mentioned earlier there are no
rules in this office and there's a very
important reason for that because
when it comes to the elections
the elections really belong to the
people
and it should be elected representatives
of the people who make
the decisions about how their elections
are going to be conducted so
unlike how some of you have seen on
television
i've read of late where secretaries of
state have made this decision or that
kind of a decision
in this state it's not like that
and here's an example there are 18
articles in the new hampshire
constitution
that have the secretary of state in
those articles
there are 22 in the constitution
that have governor in the article
there's no other state department like
that
that that and there's only two others
that are even mentioned in the
constitution the state
treasurer and the attorney general but
for both of those offices there are not
additional articles mandating that they
do
certain things and so
this you know over the years uh
there's been some exemplary
chairs of this committee and i can't
think of any
that was it's uh of late it's not been
as easy
to deal with the committee because
within the last decade or so there have
been
outside groups that were never involved
before in elections elections committee
didn't have
lobbyists in there being paid to try to
get
certain election related legislation
either passed or defeated
and that changed about 10 years ago and
and it has changed to some degree
the the committee
but this office works closely
with the committee uh and
it's it's important that
the individuals who create
the rules for the elections are directly
accountable
to the people like you all
are in the districts that you represent
so i'm i'm gonna uh
ask dave i'm gonna start with what
happened
just a few months ago and
where new hampshire stands
compared to the rest of the states
so so i don't know how this screen is
going to come up dave are you going to
actually do that yeah uh okay madam
sheriff i just
asked pam smarling if she could uh set
it up so i can share the screen
it's all set up for that dave you should
be able to
okay so let me see if i can
can everyone see that
i'm not getting anything no
[Music]
okay see what
you can see that right
no i can't you can't see it okay okay
here we go i think that
let's try this
looks good okay
i just noticed what's uh behind me i'm
actually
in a room in the state house on the
second floor
uh but i think this might have been done
by the senate
when what the background is
and and it's i'm the only one in this
room so this
this particular chart
you can see to the far right
2020. new hampshire
is highlighted in yellow and
again in this presidential election
we had the third highest turnout
in the country and it's based on
the number of votes that the highest
office vote and it's based on the voting
age population
and the reason that it's based
on that is because it's the only way
that you can go back
50 60 80 years
to get a true comparison of
the number of people the percentages
that were voting
because of late the last three or four
elections they've come different people
have come up with different denominators
but those don't allow you to go back to
get a
historical look so even though
we've seen that i've been told that this
election
it's been the highest in 100 years or
uh exactly the case
so you can see in this chart we go back
in this one to 1996 because that was the
first presidential election
that new hampshire had
election day registration at the polling
place
and in sort of a
pinkish color uh is the state of oregon
and the reason that that is highlighted
is because in 1996
oregon opted to get rid of its
election day registration at the polls
and decided to have everyone sent
a ballot who was a registered voter
for the election they do not have any
polling places
in oregon everyone gets a ballot by mail
as long as that person is a registered
voter and
they have multiple days and multiple
locations to return
that ballot so
in this from 96 to
every one of those presidential
elections oregon did that
their turnout has been lower than in new
than new hampshire now
the the second chart that sort of looks
like this
uh goes back to 1976
that was the year i became secretary of
state through 1992
and you will see that oregon had
turnouts higher
in every one of those presidential
elections than new hampshire
and between 92 and 96 the secretary of
state of oregon tried
to convince me to go to all male voting
because he said that if we did it on the
east coast they were going to do it on
the west coast
and that we would solve the voting
problem in the country
because this would make it so that
everybody
will vote and you can see so the
the first five presidential elections
that
that are included here where new
hampshire
was in the yellow and
the one time that we were below the
country
was in 1984. and we learned a lesson
from that election
because on the ballot actually
there were more than one page
there were 13 constitutional amendment
questions
and in many of the cities the ones that
had lever voting machines they only had
10 voting machines per ward so those of
you from manchester think about this
there were 10 places where you could
vote whereas now when you go into your
polling place in manchester
there's 60 or even 75 booths
that you can vote in so that's how many
people can vote at one time
in 1984 there were only ten
and with the questions people were in
the booth
longer because they had a page and a
half
of that had these 13 questions
and that was the only time so even
though all day long the news reports
were that it was massive turnout in new
hampshire no one had seen anything like
this
there were lines everywhere in the state
and it turned out to be the lowest of
our turnouts
and we learned from that and the
legislature dealt with that you can't
have more than three questions
at a time so that's the
the green line on the right of the one
you're looking at that's sort of the
demarcation
when we then went to 96
you see the complete reverse that
new hampshire in 96 went ahead of oregon
and we have been a
head of oregon in every election since
and when you read national stories you
will often
see that oregon is considered by the
academic experts said that's the best
place in the country because that's the
the least effort a voter has to make
to be able to vote and that countries
i mean the states should be like oregon
because that is the way to do it
and these this factual
data shows factually
what had happened so this time
we were you can you can see the states
that were have been above us
minnesota and maine
and what's that and wisconsin so if you
go back to
you go back to the last five you'll see
wisconsin was in third we were fourth in
and then we've been third but those are
the four
states and so what is the difference
well new hampshire does not have a
durational residency requirement
wisconsin has a 28-day residence
requirement minnesota has
30 days in its constitution
and but it also has in its statutes
20 days in a precinct
or what they call out there the place
you actually
vote and so that's the difference
between minnesota
and wisconsin and new hampshire and the
difference between
maine and new hampshire and you see
maine have been just
barely above us and then they've been
below us back in 12.
maine is not exempt from the national
voter registration act like new
hampshire
is because maine does did not qualify
to qualify to be exempt you had to have
election day registration at the polling
place
and maine didn't have that they had
election day registration
but they didn't have it statewide at the
polling place
you could register but you have to go to
the clerk's office
or some other place to register on
election day
and then go to vote so those
there are some other
differences but those are the
considerable ones
so you can you can see in these chats
you can
pull out any state you want and
do your own coloring in uh
whether the state has been on a
a a trajectory of going higher
or whether the state had been on a
trajectory of going
lower over the years and in blue you can
see where the country is
as a whole
and so this shot you can see
and then if you go back to the previous
chart
dave can you do that okay the previous
chart you can see and now
so this and now so
go back prior to 76
and uh 72 is
it's just not here but it's available
you can come up if you have if you want
to come up and
look at it it's not really much
different but
look at the turnout uh for the country
it it in 52 it was 63
using the same denominators because
that's important
using the same denominators that we have
used
all these years and you can't go back
that early
unless you use voting age population
which is the census bureau
number uh and highest vote because
for highest office and i happen to know
the person in the 70s
who work for congressional quarterly who
was given
over a year to just travel to the states
in the country that had not provided
the information back in the 50s and the
60s some states didn't
do all get all the kind of statistics
that others did and so in order to have
it for the country he was given the
opportunity to do that
and when he finished it he sent it up to
me
that's how i have it and then it was
published by the congressional research
service
this so these compilations come from
those statistics
in this if you had looked at
the turnout for the country
in this election based on this
it was 61.4
so look back at 52 it was 63.8
56 60 64
and 68. so for new hampshire
we were 72.2 this time
compared to 61.4
for the country so if you look at new
hampshire
compared to the country in 52 we were
78.2
75.2 78.7
72.4 so the new our turnout in this
election
was the highest since 1964
because we had 72.2
and in 64 we had 72.4
uh so that's
how our numbers compare to nationally
now
when you think about this i compared the
difference between minnesota wisconsin
maine
and new hampshire what is the difference
between new hampshire then and the
country
so three of those presidential elections
in the 50s and 60s
had higher turnouts than
uh than the country
and how did people vote
in those five presidential elections in
new hampshire you had to be a resident
of the state for six months
town and city clerks could not do voter
registration
that didn't come until the 70s
back in those two decades you could
register
twice a year that's all the law required
two days and they were around the time
of the election
now towns could the supervisors could do
it more if they
wanted to but that's all that was
required in the law
and you had to pay a poll tax in order
to be able to vote
in these five presidential elections
so by looking at it you can see
that the will of those
who could vote existed because
they did there were a lot of
people who could have voted during those
five presidential elections but weren't
allowed to
because of provisions in their states
and yet their numbers as part of the
voting age population were included
so even though a substantial number of
the population
was not able to vote the voting age
population
compared to the turnout for highest
office
was for three of them
out of the five and we're more
than we have had since in the country
as a whole has had since with all the
changes
that have taken place since those two
decades
and that's a uh certainly a challenge
how to bring back the will
of the people in this country
who can vote to vote
and so uh that's
that's where we are and then uh
after our election
not quite three weeks after but the
granite state poll was conducted
at the universities and they did
they did this survey before the
presidential primary and after the
presidential primary
and they did it again in november before
the general election and after the
general election
very substantial uh statistics came out
of this
that were very similar both for the
presidential primary and
for this for the past november election
uh and i'm going to bring one of them
there's others like accuracy
how the people of new hampshire feel
about their
vote is it actually counted the way they
cast
and uh extremely high compared
to the rest of the country and this
question
ease of voting was asked back in the
winter
and again in november and
it's remarkable that if you i think
it's cutting off the but
those who voted by absentee this was a
poll if you had looked at
the first page over 1900
were polled about this and they were
asked before the election
what they thought how easy they thought
it was going to be
and how accurate and then after the
election
and these are the numbers after
they're higher than before uh
they're really high so those who voted
by absentee ballot
and this time we had about 31
of the ballots were absentee in the
november election
and uh it came to about 262
000 out of 814 000
who voted those who voted absentee
if you add very easy 85
found it to be very easy and
13 founded
to be somewhat easy that's 98
and voting in person 90
found it to be very easy and nine
percent
found it to be somebody just it's
actually a little over
99 now that that
is a reflection of the 814 000
people that actually cast ballots
whether by absentee or at the polling
place
and it's pretty remarkable uh
that any poll that's in the 90
percentile
is considered suspect
by those who did it but this
has not only been the case in november
but that was
also the case in the presidential
primary
and this question has been asked by the
granite state poll in previous
years as has the question about how
accurate the people of this state
so the
that's what happened uh in
november it was different because of the
pandemic
and there was a lot of concern whether
how it would even take place
because of all the anxiety that existed
uh but
that's that's what we can report
to you statistic-wise
the polls a poll some people
have a lot of faith and paul some people
have very little
faith but the statistics are
factual and
so uh this session
good luck we're all we're here
you have anything that you
any question that you might have uh
hopefully this building will be open in
a few months
and but you can come in
uh you have to just let us know
so that security will let you come in in
the morning
the uh the legislation
at the end of the session last year the
only legislation
was regarding election laws that passed
was
a legislation that was bipartisan in
nature
where both parties had leaders of the
house and senate
come together and that and anything else
ended up not getting through
and what did get through was a big help
at the local level and
allowed new hampshire to
have the numbers that we had 814 000
is and and the numbers now on the
checklist we're we're virtually
you know we're in the 90 plus percentile
of people that can vote
being on the checklist and
and in our voting age
our voting age population
includes people who aren't even eligible
to vote
it includes people in new hampshire
who are incarcerated felons
they're part of the voting age
population but they can't vote
and that's part of the difference made
in new hampshire maine allows
felons who are incarcerated
to vote so two years four years ago
we were in second place in the country
when you
based the base when the denominator was
the voting eligible population we were
second
and maine was third in that same
election based on voting age
maine was first and we were third
because when you allow more
people to be able to vote like maine
when the denominator is voting age
they do better uh
and that's not uh and and in some states
where they have a higher percentage
than we do of people living in the state
but are not eligible to vote because
they're not u.s citizens
that plays that's a factor as well
but why we use voting age
is because it is the only way you can
have an historical perspective
and you don't read that in the national
media
you don't see this type of historical
perspective
because for some reason
they don't want to use it and in the
last three elections
there are groups out there that have
come up with different denominators
for and they show sort of different
rankings and but you can't go back
using those new type of denominators to
get
a true perspective from the past
so that's that's all
that i have at this point i'll get to
see
get to meet those of you who are
freshmen
and congratulations a lot of you this
was your first
choice and it's such an important
part of our government it's the most
important part because it's the one part
that affects everybody every person uh
who has the right under our constitution
and our laws
to vote what you do you
provide that for them and it's the one
thing that a lot of people in the
country that's all
the only part that they ever play as
part of their government
is the voting process and
we can be proud of the people of this
state
and when you look at those where
you know the participation level
thank you very much mr secretary it's it
was a
pleasure to get that update on the the
data
that has been done in regards to the
machine and i know you've always been
very accessible to committee members and
i know you will be over the next two
years so
thank you and one of these days i might
have one tenth of your ability to
remember
numbers from free recall because it
always
astounds me i don't know how you did it
but thank you
if i might just talk a little bit about
the the last election
uh because as you all know it was
unprecedented
you know having to deal with a pandemic
crisis
something that every state in the
country had to do but uh
you know this all started about a year
ago
and very quickly we realized that
it was going to take a major effort to
be able to conduct an election safely
you know making sure that everybody all
the voters had an opportunity to
exercise
their uh right to vote safely
and so you know we started early on
communicating with local election
officials
uh secretary gardner put together a
select committee on
emergency election support you were a
member of that from the legislature
along with senator sherman and some
other individuals that were familiar
with new hampshire elections
to take a look at the federal funds that
were
being made available to support the
elections in new hampshire
and to help determine on how those funds
should be
effectively spent and
after after all the great work on
on that committee uh input from local
election officials
uh new hampshire did end up spending
about a million dollars
on ppe uh personal protective equipment
that was distributed to all the polling
places around new hampshire
and you know our the input that we heard
from voters and election officials was
that
whether it was the state primary or the
general election
generally the voters felt safe going to
the polling place
and approximately 70 percent of the
voters did do just that in both the
primary and the general election
additionally uh we ended up uh
giving about 2.6 in excess of 2.6
million dollars directly to the cities
and towns
in support of their efforts in
conducting the election
uh those monies were based on
the number of absentee ballots that were
sent out by the municipal clerks
and the costs that were associated with
that
with with some of the federal funds we
hired an accounting firm
that worked with the the federal
government the election assistance
commission
to make sure that we could come up with
basically a one-size-fits-all
formula based on absentee ballots as a
simple method to reimburse cities and
towns
for the costs that they incurred and
so that was also a successful program
fortunately they have some ppe left that
you know that they're able to use in the
municipal elections and
uh you know hopefully that'll get us
through this year and beyond the covet
the crisis altogether um
we utilize this format zoom to
communicate with local election
officials
it turned out to be an incredible tool
something that i'm sure that we will
continue to use for communication and
training
well beyond the pandemic that we're
dealing with
at the moment um it was not unusual for
us to have
uh a couple hundred plus uh
participants on those zoom calls and it
was
it was amazing the way that we were able
to communicate get the word out
and we saw through those communications
uh comments and input from local
election officials that boarded on panic
in the early days to just a really calm
uh
sense as we approached elections where
they all felt prepared and ready
for the election and that was a very
rewarding thing to see
and and a big relief on our end too to
you know to see that get pulled off the
way that it did
um jumping over to uh an area that
some of you are familiar with but you
probably have questions about
you'll hear more about and that is the
hava
component of the secretary of state's
office our elections division
hava stands for the help america vote
act and
back in 2002 the federal government
passed some requirements through a
federal act that required every state in
the country to create a statewide
centralized voter database
something that you will hear commonly
referred to as election net
where all of the registered voters in
the state of new hampshire are put
input into that system along with their
personal data
part of the help america vote act
required the
the um that we provide accessible voting
equipment
in every polling place in the state of
new hampshire
and we are on the second generation of
those devices now um and
uh recently in the last election we made
some significant
upgrades to the ability for
individuals who are blind to be able to
vote by absentee
uh on home at home using their computer
as part of that process um
the federal government gave us uh
well at the time it was about 17 million
dollars
um we spent the money that was required
to meet the requirements
the mandates of the help america vote
act again creating the database and
providing the accessible voting
equipment
but we have probably nine million
dollars
uh still in that account that where we
are using
the interest basically to continue to
pay for
the funds that are required from that
federal mandate so at this point
we have kept new hampshire from having
to dip into its general fund
to pay for something that is required by
the feds
and we hope to continue that well into
the future so that
these programs are paid for by federal
money and not state money
there's also about three million dollars
that was put into that fund
a couple of years ago if you remember
before covid
the the big concern and crises uh
in the election arena was cyber security
and making sure that our election
systems are safe and secure
that you know we could reduce the risks
of
being hacked especially by foreign
entities
and new hampshire has done quite a bit
in that regard as well
you don't hear about it much now because
covet has taken the
screen front and center but we have done
quite a bit to safeguard
our uh our database systems related to
elections
and also the
the accessible voting equipment and and
the
um optical scan accounting equipment
that we can't use in the polling places
on election day so you know we can
answer more questions in that regard is
you have public hearings and these uh
these topics come up i
i looked at the number of bills that are
already assigned to your committee and i
see it's
it's up to 50 already so we're going to
be seeing a lot of each other
and um madam chair i don't know if you
have any questions that you want to ask
now or whether you just prefer that we
wait
uh until the hearings but we're
available
thank you uh i'll ask um do committee
members have
any questions i do want to say that we
do have a hard stop
um coming up uh pam smarling has another
meeting
she has to do at one o'clock and i think
it would be nice to
let her be able to log on early and have
some lunch um
so i'm more than happy to take questions
but
uh keep in mind we're going to have lots
of opportunity i do
see a question um this is good practice
so
representative trojan please
thank you madam chair thank you mr
scanlon for taking the
questions earlier dominion was brought
up
uh in the conversation um and
everybody's
heard of the stories of some problems
with them and
uh and those machines being connected to
the internet
for various reasons it's my
understanding that the machines were
using a divo
you did mention earlier that um those
that company
that system is now owned by dominion are
any of
our towns or municipalities connecting
those machines to the internet
uh at all with the with the data you
know
the the vote count in the machine
at any time no the the answer is no
the all of the machines that are used in
new hampshire
are stand-alone devices and at the end
of the night
there is a results tape that is printed
out
if it is a community it uses multiple uh
devices uh they printed a results tape
out
for each device and then they they they
physically add those together
to it to uh to reach a total
the the modems that
can be in those machines have been used
for the machines that are in service
in new hampshire and in addition to that
all of the external ports on those
devices have also been disabled
so the only cord that comes out of those
machines that can be plugged into
anything is
power cord and
and and so that's the state of the
machines that we use here
prior to their use in any given election
uh there is a memory card that is
provided by the vendor that services and
maintains those devices
uh that is tested uh prior to the
election to make sure that
the machine is counting boats properly
and then
that card is left in the machine the
cards are sealed with a numbered seal
the the machines
they're themselves in a bag where
they're not in use
all of the openings on those devices
have numbered seals on them and every
municipal clerk
is possibly required by statute to keep
a log of those seals
and uh make a note notation in the log
every time those seals are broken
and then the number of the new seal that
is placed on it
so there's a lot of security that that
surrounds those devices
it was not to say that you know those
machines could not be
hacked somehow because any electronic
device we recognize can be
but but the the way that they are
maintained
kept secure with logs kept of them
dramatically reduces the risk of
something nefarious
occurring and for something major to
happen in new hampshire would require
a significant conspiracy
thank you thank you very much well i am
sure that we'll be hearing a lot about
that as we go
as we go on this year representative
lane
uh thank you uh i recall last year
going to a couple different for the
voting machines that people came in and
showed the voting machines because
there was some discussion about getting
because as you mentioned
our voting machines are kind of getting
long in the tooth
uh so i was just curious where
what you expect to see about that and
will we be
hearing about that more or what the
status of that is
we will certainly be hearing about that
that more um some of those
initiatives were put on the back burner
because of the covet crisis and
everything that we were dealing with
um the the the
the the issue with the vendors that
showed up was that
we're having difficulty finding just a
single standalone counting device
that will count balance and the the
vendors that
that came to the sessions that we had
uh where you know we were testing them
out
have they they want to sell a package so
it's not only the machine that counts
the ballots but they want to sell their
software program
to go along with it that that designs
the ballots
and um
has a lot more bells and whistles than
we actually need
um that's not to say that we may not end
up with
you know one of those entities in the
future it's just
we want to make sure that we get what
makes sense for new hampshire
the other thing that we're going to be
talking about i'm sure this session is
going to be the e-pull books
and where that stands and
you know that is is moving along but
slowly
um you know there have been some
localities in new hampshire that have
tested those devices
um and we've been able to see what the
benefits are that work well and but
we've also been able to see where the
flaws are
um and so that'll be that'll be part of
the discussion this year
and the other thing that we did recently
uh as a result of a bill that was passed
through the senate
that required us to test high-speed
scanners for auditing purposes
after the general election um
uh which which we did um and
you know there's some interesting
results i mean
you know the technology is really
improving and they were able to go
through
a you know a town's ballots very quickly
with uh with results that matched up
closely with
you know what the counts were on
election day we didn't use the 2020
results we were we were using ballots
from the 2018 election
but uh but we'll be able to report more
on that uh
you know at a different time thank you
thank you representative prudhomme brian
oh uh okay so my question is
uh it echoes what uh representative
hammer
was asking about and that is
um what you answered also um
mr scanlan is that on
the frequently asked questions section
of the secretary of state's website so
when we get
these questions by our constituents we
can
send them right to you to get those the
same answers about
our equipment that's used
and everything that you just said
basically yeah um
which i'm gonna have to look at our
frequently asked questions on the
website i'm not sure that
that that one is there um it is
it is a question that has been
frequently asked of us
on the phone and um you know we have
developed
you know kind of a standard response um
[Music]
which we have published but you know let
me see if we can make that more readily
available to you
and your constituents
thank you deputy scanlon there is a lot
of information on the secretary of
state's website i
recommend that committee members um
spend some time on it there's a lot of
new information
since this committee met last year
and uh if we've got questions about it
we'll be seeing deputy scanlon quite
often i suspect and we'll be able to ask
him
in the committee format
of meetings does anybody else have any
questions right now
because if we are all set
i'd like to thank deputy scanlan for and
secretary gardner for being with us
today
and i want to take a few minutes to talk
to committee members about our first
meeting
which will be happening a week from now
you should have all received an email
notice
of the meeting next week at 10 o'clock
you should have also received a email
from paul
smith requesting your preferred email
for notices
if you want to keep using your ledgey
email but you have another email you
would prefer
or you check more regularly i would
suggest trying to
set up an automatic forwarding of some
sort
i'm now way out of my lead league from a
technology standpoint but i know you can
do it
to make sure that you get those notices
you saw yesterday
how we had a hearing notice sent and
within
an hour i think you had another hearing
notice sent that said revised hearing
notice
and um it is difficult to keep track of
what's going on especially if it's
buried in your allegy email with all the
bulk email we get
so committee hearing next week
this committee won the lottery so to
speak
and got the call to have the first
public hearing
um we will be the first one and the only
one occurring next week for various
reasons in state health scheduling it
is scheduled for friday at 10 o'clock
as we get a little more depth with the
system
we will probably discuss as a committee
moving up the beginning time to nine
o'clock especially if most people
are attending remote you will be able to
attend remote
for the meetings i will i am planning to
physically be
at the state house next week uh
you have the option to do so if you want
um i really want to be there to see the
setup really the public will not be
allowed to be in the building the
building is not open to the public
they have supposedly arranged double
committee rooms
with adequate spacing and
a large screen at the end of the tables
that will project something like we're
looking
a so that if you are in attendance you
will have the ability to see that screen
we are have not
gotten any word that you would be
allowed to bring your own computer and
there are issues in regards to the
access to the format
that they're concerned about so you
would not be able to have a computer
right now
at least at the table in front of you so
you would be looking at the screen
at the end of the room so for many of
you you're going to find that this
format is
actually more useful there
the clerk will need to
do her duties as is normal i need to
tell you
we're sort of still working that out
veteran members recall the old pink
cards and sign up sheets
it is my understanding that notices will
go
out and if members of the public want to
testify in regards to a bill
there will be an ability to sign up
ahead of time
and i chairs will be provided a list
of people who want to speak before the
meeting
and i expect that the direction will be
if you sign up ahead of time
you're going to be recognized before
people who sign up on the day of the
hearing
this is apparently a format that the
senate has been using
so we're going to give it a try here in
the house
i will report on the setup and try to
maybe visually be able to
let people who are attending remotely
see what the room is set
up like the other issue is going to be
that during the meeting
we will need to have a technology person
doing what has been going on today
recognizing people who raise their hands
recognizing them to speak
um and trying to work it out the
legislative assistants will not
be available to run the technology
during the meeting
we don't have enough staff to provide
the
the research support that we need in
addition to
being in every room i will tell you that
one of the reasons i'm going in
next week is because i want to do
the technology piece of it during the
first public hearing so we can see how
well it's really working
to see what the feasibility is of having
someone do that remotely because that
can be done obviously remotely i've been
doing it here this morning
i have significant concerns that if
there's a problem
i would rather be on site to resolve it
so that we don't have to cancel any
meetings
or reschedule anything because as you
heard we have 50 plus
bills so committee meeting next
week at 10 o'clock you'll be getting a
zoom invitation
we ask that you log on early i am going
to try and start the meeting
early i mean start the meeting at 10
o'clock
um and we have three bills
originally our public hearing was
scheduled for one bill
that was sb2 sb2 is the bill that has
already come out of the senate it is
amended to deal with issues as you heard
stated in regards to
our community elections and
annual meetings that start
really in february i believe some have
something scheduled at the beginning
end of january one of the reasons they
wanted that dealt with
quickly was because public notices
needed to happen for those meetings
and have already happened
however there was some discussion that
we should deal with this with a public
hearing because to have dealt with this
bill right away
would have eliminated the ability to
have a public hearing on it
so sb 2 went to the top of the list for
public hearings
that was scheduled for 10 o'clock next
friday
as bills got processed the offices have
to take
care to make sure that bills going to a
second committee are taken
care of second committee bills are bills
that need to go to finance
generally and they need to be reported
out by february 18th out of this
committee
so there are two bills on our
list that need to go to finance one is
hb
86 that is a recently added bill
and it does it is relative to voter
qualifications and registration
procedures
and the other bill that has a fiscal
note is
121 which is relative to independent
redistricting commissions
so as you know um independent
redistricting commissions have had
robust
public hearings but
and so i was reluctant to put that on
however given our attempt to try and
manage committee meetings
and not have them every day we're going
to be limited to
i think two days a week once committee
meetings get going
um we've put them all on for next week
i have optimistically scheduled them for
an
hour each in the hopes we do not
have to take a lunch break because i'm
concerned about the technology
doing a break and coming back both for
committee members
and the public but we're gonna we'll do
that if we need to
um and once a hearing is noticed if
we're going way over
um the committees that the committee
hearings that follow as you know for
those of you who have been in person
they're just gonna start late and we'll
try to get a handle on that
to let people know if we think it is
going to go late
you can get the bills by going online
to the advanced bill search frankly i
find is the easier site
and go to election law bills and look up
the bills
i do not suggest printing them out i
will tell you that this
is the stack of bills and this is
largely double-sided printed
so um my suggestion would be
that you i'm a big paper person i want
to put them in a notebook and organize
them i'm trying to hold back
um because we have more bills i think
than
i have i certainly have seen on election
law and i
suspect the most we have ever had
we will not be having an executive
session next week
you will notice that the calendar notice
says there may be
but i will tell you as chair we will not
be
um there was because of the last minute
nature of the scheduling the clerk's
office was not
sure about the executive session and
that
um language was selected to go in
just to be sure we were covered if for
some reason
we did have an executive session but
given the number of public hearings we
now have i don't think a vote is likely
which means that
we will have to have another meeting
before february 18th on or before
february 18th
i do not after our meeting on
the 22nd i do not expect to be
scheduling a meeting before
february 1st and i am hoping to know
shortly what days of the week we have
been given
to hold our public hearings there is an
issue of
public access and scheduling
and it's my understanding that
committees are going to be given
particular days of the week
it has also been requested that we
schedule bills to go
all day because of the number of bills
that we have
um i know like for like many of you
i sort of multitask and usually have
tried to have something else on my
calendar
on committee hearing days i'm not sure
that's going to be possible
as we begin this journey so
with the january calendar
probably just being our meeting on the
22nd
you can expect at least one meeting out
of this committee
before the 18th and i will tell you that
there is not going to be a session from
what i've heard before the second week
in february
because really the first thing we need
to do as
a body is to deal with second committee
bills those don't actually have to be
voted on the body
by the body until the 25th and i
apologize for that ding i'm going to
have to have a conversation with
um it as to operating
the sound off my camera as compared to
my computer
my computer is telling me other things
are happening i have no idea what they
are
so that's i you know about all i know
about these committee meetings
and as soon as i know anything else
definitively
i will send it out i know people are
asking about
executive sessions and attendance and
how that is going to happen
and as soon as i know
i will let you know but it's my
understanding they believe they have
committee rooms set up so
that some or all members would be able
to
attend safely and just to repeat
i will physically be there next friday
that's the plan
because of my concern over making sure
we've got all the moving pieces set up
correctly for
our meetings so with that uh
representative lane
you're muted sorry
operator error um
[Music]
for those who do go into them into the
building
for the meetings will there be a mask
requirement
i am assuming so pam are you online is
there a mask requirement in the building
yes there's currently the facilities
committee um
directive about masks is is
still in place thank you
any other questions uh representative
pruitt palmer barnes
um do we need to
tell people ahead of time that we intend
to be there
on the 22nd at the meeting
is there any accommodation that they
need to make for that
i don't believe so but pam you want to
answer that
it would be helpful i am sure yeah i
i haven't heard about you know final um
decisions but that's definitely been
um among the proposals that just so we
know
who to expect and it would certainly be
helpful
and it may be required i just don't know
um what the final decision will be
but we will get that information in the
next few days
yes absolutely they're they're working
on it right now
i will be there literally right now
thank you thank you representative
derozan
thank you madam chair um pretty much
echoing uh
representative o'brien's question i
intend to be there um
next friday in person um so i just want
to make sure we can get in the building
if
we need to notify somebody to even get
in you know with social security if that
will be done
uh by you or uh
any other questions
i'm not seeing any hands i think i'm
looking at the screen correctly
pam help me if i'm wrong i don't see any
hands
all right so um if there are no other
questions i'm going to
conclude this orientation meeting
i want to thank you all for attending i
hope you found it helpful
if there's more information after
thinking about this you'd like
let me know and we'll try to put time in
our
agenda maybe to address other things as
a committee
we have the opportunity to invite guests
in
to discuss particular issues like
representative lane referenced in
regards to replacement machines or
you also heard some reference in regards
to
the audit trial that was done at the
archives i had the opportunity to see
that
and you might have questions that might
go or
what is involved in that and so just
know that those kind of issues we can
deal with in
addition to the bills three bills next
week
and if there's nothing further uh
i guess i'm gonna call an end to this
they're not requiring a roll call to end
the meetings are they
pam no no thank you
so a big buy is okay
okay thank you this was very helpful all
right and there's a leave
meeting button at the bottom right of
your screen